it's pretty unique yeah I mean it's
definitely a new environment that I
don't think has really been explored and
the passage of time and the way you go
in and out of certain time periods I
think is is pretty unusual and it's done
in a way that if I could say you can
keep track of because sometimes you just
don't know what's going on when people
are changing times and in places and so
I think Sam has found a style that makes
everything really clear mm-hmm
and for you what was it that you grabbed
you I mean aside from working with Julia
Roberts I mean really no that was the
big grab for sure um but no it was just
such a great podcaster the podcast was
the first you know time I've heard of
this sort of story and and you know I've
always been fascinated by thrillers and
anything that keeps you on the edge of
your seat I love suspense and I've
really never gotten to do a project like
this so for me it was really exciting to
do a television show
you know my second television show to be
a part of something that people could
fall in love with can continuously watch
and and you know like you said you were
you were binge watching and so I think
that that was the goal for me once I
heard the podcast like binge listened to
it so really yes yeah those things you
can't stop watching yeah so I think that
you know I got that that's sort of a
feeling and hoped that we could do the
same thing in in a TV show Julie I'm
sure you've been asked to do TV series
many times but what was it about this
one for you to make that jump it was
just you know the right time in the
right place and I'm a great admirer of
Sam s mails work and when he came on and
and talked to me about it for me the key
was for him to direct all of them which
I knew was a big request okay and he
didn't say yes immediately though he
sort of talks like he did he did not it
was a very good
later yeah so I think he had to get his
mr. robot ducks in a row yeah and so we
lucked out to have him be a god yeah
awesome and to have it premiere here in
Toronto what does that feel like for
both of you you both are no strangers to
Toronto well I mean you're you're our
boy what 2015 you were one to watch the
best of all words rising star what does
this feel like it's incredible it's an
incredible sort of a full-circle moment
just driving here I was just like
remembering all the street cars and
subway rides I would take to my
auditions out here and now to just be
here and to have two projects that were
bringing to the festival um you know the
first time that anyone's gonna get to
see these things it's here in my
hometown so you know just a really
really special special moment for me and
Julia Roberts is here well I mean that's
right and you have the best wingman
right or woman right and to do this with
and for you Julia what does it feel like
you know in Toronto it's it's a real
film crowd and people who do love the
craft do you feel that when you're here
or do you just like being in in Toronto
more than anything I'm so excited for
Stefan's mom yeah because it's there's
nothing more just remarkable than when
you come home with your success to
present and and he's so incredible he's
the consummate professional he is it was
such an eye-opening experience for me to
get to have this new moment in my career
and make this television show and to be
with Stefan and really the things that
we accomplished these were not small
tasks that were laid before us on a
daily whether the trenches together well
mentally I heard it was difficult
shooting this was that because of the
there was some really big dialogues
there yeah it seemed like or what was it
everything I was a headliner
everything was 11 pages in to take you
know which is 11 minutes that's a very
long time when it's just two people
sitting in a room
I get it so yeah um I have to ask this
question because everybody at my office
wants to know oceans eight
did you see it and will you do oceans
nine I didn't see it would you do it
there's an oceans nine I don't know
there could be you said the way if you
said that you do admit that probably
would happen I I did all my oceans I
mean baby do it there's more ocean yeah
I spend a lot of time in it so that's so
we don't know guys I tried I just we
don't know